Naja
Noch keiner da
Wie kann das sein
Wo sind die Subbox Camper
Lul weh
Wub lul
Festgestellt, dass ich meinen
Overlays auch gar nicht gestartet habe
Und KS
Ok S
Ich habe mir ein neues Mikrofon gekauft
Zum Aufnehmen von Technik Videos
Vielleicht probieren wir das nachher mal aus
Aktuell bin ich ganz normal
Über meine Zeit am Start
Clani am Start, Silent Pain am Start
Aja ja
Kannst du ein gutes Auto Interface empfehlen?
Ich kenne mich da nicht so gut aus
Ich kann dir nur sagen welches ich habe
Und welches ich schon seit 8 Jahren oder so verwende
Ohne jegliche Probleme
Aber das ist zu teuer
Gibt es glaube ich auch gar nicht mehr
Das ist zu teuer für einfach so
Das ist natürlich geil
Wenn man verschiedene Sachen anschließen will
Wenn man eine Konsole anschließen will
2 PCs anschließen will
XLR Eingänge ein paar brauche
Und optische Eingänge brauche oder so
Da ist das ganz nice
Aber für einfach nur ein Mikrofon anschließen
Und ein bisschen was natürlich zu teuer
Aber das ist das einzige Audio Interface was ich je hatte
Und das habe ich jetzt schon 8 Jahre lang
Und ist wirklich richtig gut das Ding
Ist halt viel zu teuer
Für ein bisschen sowas
Also ich meine 440 Euro
Das war damals noch ein Ticken teurer
Aber die positive Bewertung finde ich sprechend für sich
Das schöne daran ist
Du hast ein Audio Knöpfchen vorne dran
Wo du verschiedene Funktionen lauter, leiser
Eingabequellen durchschalten kannst
Du hast die Eingabe
Hier vorne die Inputs
Und hinten hast du noch mal so ein Breakout Kabel
Wo dann im Endeffekt
Ich weiß nicht ob sie dein Bild dabei haben
Wo du glaube ich 16 Sachen anschließen kannst
Ich weiß nicht ob die hier die Bilder haben
Mit dem Breakout Kabel
Aber hier guck
Da hast du glaube ich 4 XLR Anschlüsse
Du hast ein paar fette Klinkendinger
Du hast sogar so ein MIDI Interface
Das was man wahrscheinlich bloß noch als Keyboard Spieler braucht
Keine Ahnung
Das ist wirklich nice
Theoretisch kannst du sogar ein paar Firewire anschließen
Falls das irgendjemand im Jahr 2019 noch haben will
Aber das ist wirklich gut
Du kannst dir ja unten mal deinen Zettel verlinken mit Amazon vorstellen
Das hatte ich früher
Hatte auch Fettkohle gebracht
Ich war zu faul es zu aktualisieren
Deswegen
Schreibe ich mir gleich mal auf
Muss ich mal wieder machen
Weil Amazon Ref links bringen passiv
übelst viel Kohle. Doch doch das hat 6,3 mm Klinkeanschlüsse, 2 Stück, 3,5 mm Klinkeanschlüsse,
2 Stück vorne und hier am Breakout Kabel hast du auch noch ein paar. Du hast Inputs hast
du wirklich mehr als genug und das beste ist, du hast sogar, du hast sogar einen optischen
Input, der entweder, wie heißt das, dieses normale SPDIF oder so kann, oder kann sogar
ADAT mit 8 Channels, 6 Channels und so was und du kannst sogar durchschleifen in und
out. Also das hat alles, das hat wirklich alles, was man irgendwie braucht. Es kostet
ein bisschen was und ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ob es das beste ist oder sonst was,
es hat sogar noch Firewire Anschluss. Hier vorne kannst du die Mikros umschalten. Also
das Gesamtpaket fand ich das damals super und ich bin bis heute davon überzeugt. Also
der Kauf, der hat sich wirklich mal gelohnt. Das geht seit 8 Jahren oder so schon ohne
Probleme das Ding. Ja aber das mit Amazon verlinken, das mache ich dann mal so, mal
gucken. Ja und nachher, wenn im Stream alle da sind, wir können mal, ich habe mir für,
ich habe mir ein Mikro gekauft für, ist nichts dolles, ja, siehst du auch schon, dass es
einen Klinkeanschluss hat, aber der Hersteller ist ganz gut, von dem habe ich schon so ein
Mikrofon für Interviews oder so, nicht dass ich oft Interviews mache oder so. Aber ich
habe mir mal ein Mikrofon gekauft, was ein bisschen Kabel hat, was ich an meinen Zoom
Audio Recorder anschließen kann für, wenn ich Technikvideos aufnehme. Also sprich, wenn
ich dann wieder am Tisch stehe und ein bisschen rumlabern und so was, weil der Sound, der
Sound beim letzten Video war jetzt ja schon nicht so toll. Stimmt, Max, ich glaube du
hast Recht, der muss glaube ich sogar Klinke haben, weil die Stromversorgung nur darüber
gescheit funktioniert, die brauchen ja nur ganz wenig, aber sie brauchen Strom. Ich
glaube die müssen, ich glaube die müssen sogar Klinke haben. Ja, weil der Sound hier
war ja nicht sonderlich gut, ne, der Sound ist schon, es halt sehr, weil das halt im Wohnzimmer
unten aufgenommen ist und ich habe es zwar mit dem Audio Recorder aufgenommen, ich habe
es mit dem Audio Recorder und der Kamera gleichzeitig aufgenommen, aber es halt halt einfach im
Raum. Soll ich das Mikrofon mal auspacken und ranstecken, wollen wir mal ausprobieren
wie sich das anhört? Kann das ja einfach mal ranstecken, wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Ja, mach mal, ok, ich probiere das mal aus, frisch verpackt von Amazon, kommen wir hier,
ok, jetzt haben wir Unboxing. Wo habe ich denn jetzt dagegen geschmissen, ich habe einfach
gesagt, ich muss es mal aufmachen. Ok, das ist schon mal ganz cool verpackt, ist in so
einem Beutel drin, ist so ein komisches Salz dabei, was kein Mensch braucht, eigentlich
sollte angeblich auch ein Headset-Bügel dabei sein, aber ist nicht, oder? Hä, ich dachte,
da soll so ein Bügel dabei sein, guckt mal. Ich glaube, das ist, ach ne, das ist, da ist
nicht dabei, das ist quasi, das ist wie bei Essens-Serviervorschlag. Ok, ich probiere
das jetzt mal aus, also hier ist so ein Klippse, hier ist so ein Klippse dabei, ich probiere,
ich mache mir das jetzt mal als T-Shirt hier dran und dann stöpsel ich es mal um und wir
probieren das aus. Warning, haha, das ist ja geil, ich weiß nicht, sieht man hier irgendwo
auf dem Ding? Ey, da ist, da ist ein Mikrofon, das sieht so aus, nur das hier, das hier ein
Warning dran ist, Warning, Strangulation Hazard, also Achtung, dass ich mich nicht damit erhänge
mit dem Kabel. Strangulation Hazard. This cable contains Kevlar and has the potential risk of
causing strangulation. Avoid looping the cable around the neck and keep out of reach of children.
Gut, das musste jetzt mal gesagt werden. Also Leute, hofft mal, dass ich mich nicht erwürge
mit dem Kabel jetzt irgendwie, ne, also man kann ja alles passieren. Auf der Rückseite
von Tastaturen steht auch, dass das Verwenden einer Tastatur zu schweren gesundheitlichen
Schäden führen kann. Just ma, Stufe 2, nein Stufe 1, abonniert drei Monate, Dankeschön,
Vollgas, Alter. Moment, stimmt gar nicht, gar kein Prime. IQ steigt wieder ins unermessliche
hier. So, ok, also, machen wir das mal auseinander. Das Kabel ist leider nicht ganz so lang, wie
ich gedacht habe, aber das ist nicht schlimm, weil so eine Klinkeverlängerung ist nur wirklich
kein, kein Ding. Drei Monate? Zwei Monate, ja. Ok, so, jetzt muss man hier irgendwie den,
wie funktioniert denn das? Wie macht man das da dran? Wie macht man das da jetzt? Fack,
wie macht man das da rein? Da ist irgendeine komische Schleife drin, da muss man das Mikro
glaube ich so rein, reinstelzen irgendwie, dass es hält. Hab ich auch immer das funktioniert?
Äh, keine Ahnung, vielleicht mach ich das jetzt kaputt. Fest ist das da jetzt aber
nicht drin. Sack voll, es waggelt. Wie macht man das? Wie, wie macht man das? So, Achtung,
wo ist das? Ah hier, da steht sogar alles dabei, wie es funktioniert. Ah, ganz anders
funktioniert es, als wie ich es gemacht habe. Ich hab's verkackt. Hab das falsch rum, falsch
rum dran gemacht. So, ich muss das eigentlich, das kommt da oben durch, das kommt da oben
durch, aha. Ihr seht doch mal, ich bin schon überfordert mit so einem poplichen Mikrofon.
Außerdem hat sich das Kabel verknotet, wie kann sich das Kabel, also Leute, wie kann
sich das Kabel verknoten? Ich hab das Kabel gerade aus der Packung gemacht, das ist eigentlich
gar nicht möglich. Ok, jetzt hab ich's, jetzt hab ich's. Jetzt ist dran. Ok, ich stöpsel
das jetzt mal dran hier an mich. So, ich hör mich jetzt halt, also ich hör mich jetzt
halt selbst nicht, ich stöpsel mich jetzt mal um. Wie mach ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Ich stöpsel mich jetzt mal um, mach ich hier vorne mal ans T-Shirt. Also ich hör mich
jetzt selbst, es kann sein, dass es übelst zu laut ist oder übelst zu leise oder so,
das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren, also haltet euch mal die Ohren zu.
Äh, es geht nicht, oder? Es hat nicht funktioniert. Ha. Ok.
Ok, wir machen noch mal was, ich hab nämlich ne Idee. Es könnte sein, dass es einfach mega
leise war und mein Noise Gate nicht. Ich mach mal kurz das Noise Gate aus. Das heißt,
ihr hört jetzt wirklich jeden Mist, egal wie leise ich laber oder nicht. So, ich stöpsel
das nochmal an, weil den Ein- und Ausschalter hat es nicht.
Ok, ich mach mal kurz das Noise Gate aus, weil den Ein- und Ausschalter hat es nicht.
Da hat jetzt nichts getan irgendwie, oder? Ha. Ska-Mast, ha? Knack-Knack.
Ist das, bin ich Ska-Mast worden, oder? Das geht nicht am PC? Das muss, ich probier
es jetzt mal an meinem Audiorecorder aus. Ich stöpsel es mal schnell an meinen Audiorecorder,
da muss es eigentlich funktionieren. So. Ok, ich stöpsel es mal an meinem Audiorecorder,
da muss es eigentlich funktionieren. Was soll das, warum geht das nicht? Hm, war jetzt
zwar so nicht geplant, aber. So. Macht es irgendwas? Blub, blub, blub. Test, Test, Test,
Test, Test, Nö. Ja, Leute. Hm. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, warum das nicht funktioniert.
Ist aber doof. Ja, aber sag mal, so in meinem Audiointerface sollte es doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Hm. Ok, keine Ahnung. Naja, muss ich nachher mal ausprobieren, muss ich jetzt ja nicht
on stream machen. Ist ja nicht nötig, aber ich hab jetzt gedacht, mich schließt das
da voran und gut ist. Aber anscheinend ist die Sache wieder deutlich komplexer als man
sich das vorstellt. So ein Mikro einfach in, so ein Mikrofon einfach in Eingang stöpseln,
das geht ja nicht. Naja, gut. Hm. Keine Ahnung, was soll das, was soll das, was soll das,
was soll das, was soll das, was soll das, was soll das, was soll das. Keine Ahnung, also
warum das nicht funktioniert, vielleicht. Also, das. China Adapter bestellen, genau,
deswegen hab ich schon Aliexpress auf. Das ist ja jetzt aber merkwürdig. Man braucht
da nen fucking Adapter für. Man braucht wirklich nen Adapter dafür, dass ich das am PC verwenden
kann. Was ist denn das für ein Crap? Ach, vielleicht kann ichs mit der Cam. Warum geht
das mit meinem Audiorecorder nicht, das fuckt mich jetzt übelst ab. Naja, gut, ähm. Wo
hab ich denn den Audiorecorder überhaupt hingeschmissen? Geht euch das teilweise auch so, dass ihr
Dinge in der Hand hattet und dann macht ihr was anderes und legt das kurz weg und dann
seht ihrs nicht mehr. Das ist richtig MonkaS. Weit, es kann doch nicht weit sein. Ach, da
ist es. Hab's auf die Erde gelegt, ne, beim Schreibtisch. Lest mal bei Amazon die erste
Frage. Aha. Rode TRS auf TRS. Oh ne, dafür brauch ich jetzt echt noch mal nen extra Adapter?
Das ist aber doof. Das ist aber doof. Ich hab noch nen Rode, ich hab noch nen Rode XLR
Adapter. Ob das damit funktioniert? Das ist nen 3,5mm Klinke auf XLR Adapter. Das können
wir mal ausprobieren, ob das damit funktioniert. Wahrscheinlich ist das Mikrofon RIP danach
oder so. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht funktionieren, wenn die Pins nicht
da sind. Ah ja. So, angestöpselt ist es, aber macht gar nix. Na geil. Ok Leute, RIP, dann
halt nicht. Dann bring ich das jetzt mal wieder weg. Dann probieren wir das jetzt nicht aus.
Das wäre eigentlich ne coole Sache. Ich hab mir mal vor ein paar Jahren so nen Funk-Mikrofon-Ding
bei Toman gekauft, allerdings ging mir das immer auf den Keks mit Batterien und sowas.
Ich will einfach meinen Audio-Recorder neben mich legen und gut is. Kosten dieser komische
Adapter hier. Ey, 3,5mm auf AR45, also ich bin eher dafür 3,5mm auf Gartenschlauch. Kosten
der Adapter 10 Euro. Ist das nicht euer Ernst? What the fuck? Das ist doch nix Rode-spezifisches,
das ist doch wahrscheinlich so ein ganz publischer, das kann doch nicht sein, Aliexpress. Ups,
nein, ich hab es so chinesisch umgestellt. Fuck, wie stelle ich es wieder zurück? Ja,
sowas da, das ist doch schon mal gut hier, aber das ist das falsche. Das ist genormt,
das denke ich auch. Egal, ich schmeiß jetzt das Mikrofon und den Adapter mal in die Ecke.
Enttäuschend Leute, enttäuschend. Das ist Windwacke, oder? Tickenlauter gehört die
Musik schon mal. Okay, naja, dann hat sich das zumindest schon mal erledigt. Das funktioniert
nicht, wie ich mir das gedacht hab. Also Leute, ich hab heute gar nix spezielles, oh was geht
denn jetzt im Chat ab? Ich erkenne nicht, was das sein soll. Irgendein Tintenfisch, ich
hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll. Gut, das brauchen wir nicht, weg, weg, weg, weg,
weg. Wir probieren es zwar im Stream aus, aber hat natürlich nicht funktioniert. Ganz
toll. Hab ich irgendwelche Fragen im Chat eigentlich übersehen? Gehen wir mal auf Amazon, ja, aber
da haben wir uns ja gerade schon angeguckt. Und wisst ihr, was das witzige ist? Ich hab
jetzt ja das neue iPhone aufgenötigt bekommen, es hat gar kein Klinkgestecker mehr dafür.
Beste Programmiersprache deiner Meinung nach? Das kommt immer auf den Anwendungszweck an.
Ja, nur noch Bluetooth Kopfhörer oder die neue Apple Kopfhörer, die haben jetzt einen
Lightning Anschluss. So was Beknacktes, Alter. Das wisst ihr, was ich nicht verstehe? Also
ich hab ja hier jetzt das, den Brocken hier, das XR. Und wer da allen Ernstes erzählt,
da war kein Platz mehr, den Klinkeanschluss dran zu machen, der ist echt nicht mehr ganz
dicht. Das ist das fetteste Stück, was man so in der Hose haben kann, also, also Smartphone.
Das ist ein riesen fettes Teil, das XR, da wäre Platz gewesen für 75 Klinkeanschlüsse,
aber nicht bei Apple. Ascii Spam, sind wir im Jahr 2001 oder was? Oh, Subs, ich hab was
übersehen. Der Karlsson Twitch Prime, 3 Monate, Dankeschön, Poggers. Komisch. Ist
auch bei allen Geräten so, das macht es nicht besser, wenn das bei allen Geräten so ist.
Also auf den Klinkeanschluss zu verzichten ist einfach ultrabeknackt, weil ich mein,
einen digital analoge Konverter braucht man eh schon, das Ding hat Lautsprecher, das geht
nicht ohne. Machst du mit dem Server weiter? Das weiß ich noch nicht genau. Könnten wir
eigentlich machen, ich weiß noch nicht so genau, was ich machen will, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab jetzt nichts Spezielles vor, ich hab einfach mal Streben angemacht, sonst nichts.
Wir können uns auch mal wieder ein paar Stellenanzeigen angucken, was es da interessantes gibt. Wie
gesagt, ich gucke ja immer mal wieder, also eigentlich nur zur allgemeinen Belustigung.
Hat was mit Wasserfestigkeit, tut uns die Klinke weglassen, dass halt, also ja ich glaub
dir, dass die das sagen, aber die Geräte vorher sind auch nicht abgesoffen und tauchen
will mit seinem Smart Follower kaum einer. Ne, ich glaube das ist so ein Ding, Apple hat
angefangen und die anderen machen es nach, weil. Kannst deinen Abfallsaal richten. Was
wird hier so getrieben, ja das ist noch nicht so ganz raus. Ich wollte gerade mal ein neues
Mikro testen, was ich mir für Technikvideos gekauft hab, aber festgestellt, es geht am
PC nicht. Natürlich doof gewesen. Ich kann es mal an meiner Kamera ausbringen, vielleicht
funktioniert es daran. Samsung kriegt das auch mit Klinke hin, ok. Schau das Fortnite
Event an. Ist das Fortnite Event das mit diesem schwarzen Loch? Das muss mir irgendjemand erklären,
das hab ich nicht gecheckt. Das hab ich nicht gecheckt. Was ist das überhaupt? Gibt's da
in game ein schwarzes Loch und irgendwo erscheinen Zahlen oder so, ne? Ich hab's null gecheckt,
aber ich meine ich spiele auch kein Fortnite, deswegen weiß ich das wahrscheinlich. Als
Fortnite Fan wüsste ich das wahrscheinlich sofort, ja. Did Fortnite really get deleted?
Aha, tja. Grip Fortnite. Fortnite wurde gelöscht, wenn das Google sagt. Welche Kamera hast du,
äh, irgendeinen Sony Teil? Ich weiß nicht welche, genau. Aber die reicht. Holst du dir
Modern Warfare? Ja, klar. Also ich hoffe ich krieg's. Ob ich mir holen werde, weiß ich
nicht. Ob ich mir holen würde, weiß ich nicht. Aber wenn ich's kriege, nehm ich's. Die Sache
ist nämlich die, ich gehe nämlich davon aus, dieses Jahr, dass Modern Warfare ganz ok werden
wird. Rein vom gametechnischen her. Es hat ein paar Dinge, die mir auf den Sack gehen,
aber ich glaube an sich wird's ok. Aber die werden ihr Game komplett durch irgendwelche
Lootboxkacke wieder zerstören. Ich mein, sie haben zwar vorher erst einen Tweet irgendwie
abgesetzt, dass es, dass keiner bei Infinity Ward überhaupt an einem Lootbox und Supply
Drop System arbeitet, aber ehrlich gesagt, wer glaubt diesem Blödsinn, den die erzählen,
ne? Ähm, ich erinnere mal eine Sache, der hat wortwörtlich gesagt zu Modern Warfare
3, Last Stand ist nicht im Spiel. Fuck you Last Stand. Da erinnert sich dann noch einer
dran. Dann kam das Game raus und hatte Last Stand drinne. Hieß halt anders. So, das heißt
jetzt auch anders. Ähm, und natürlich ist das wieder im Game drinne. Oder aber, sie
arbeiten nicht dran, weil sie müssen nicht mehr dran arbeiten, weil das ist schon fertig.
Alles beknackt. Totaler Blödsinn. Einfach nur die Leute skammarst, ist das. Ein Show
Me hat Klinke. Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht, warum die es nicht hinkriegen. Hach ja, PS4
exklusiv. Das ist auch so ein Ding, was mich ankotzt, ne? Diese PS-, also ich mein, dass
man ne Woche exklusive Sachen hat, vielleicht sogar nen Monat bei manchen Sachen, kann ich
ja nachvollziehen. Aber nen Bestandteil des Games für ein Jahr Exklusivität ist bescheuert.
Gibt's da eigentlich was Neues dazu? Ist da eigentlich jetzt was Neues zu mittlerweile?
Ne, das ist halt einfach so, ne? Ich mein, überlegt euch mal, es ist 2020, es kommt dann
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Black Ops, äh, Black Ops Prequel oder irgendwie sowas raus. Und
worauf wird man 2020 mehr abgehen? Oder was wird man, was wird man Oktober 2020 sagen?
Wird man sagen, yeah, Call of Duty 2020 kommt raus? Oder, yeah, ich kann jetzt endlich den
Modern Warfare, äh, äh, äh, äh, Dickens Back Ops Modus spielen. Sagt doch keiner.
an. Wub wub. Das ist, der Modus der exklusiv ist, ist dieser Spec Ops Modus aus MW3, oder
Survival, Survival, genau. Da hat man, das, das, ah fuck. Das ist auf den Multiplayer
Maps gegen Bots im Endeffekt. Es ist quasi Zombies, ohne Zombies zu sein, nur in schlechter
auf Multiplayer Maps. Also eigentlich nichts, was man wirklich vermisst, aber es ist beknackt,
dass es ein Ja exklusiv ist. Das ist, also es ist schon ein, sag mal mal ein relativ
großer Bestandteil irgendwo. Also so von dieser Sache, was sie da erzählen, das macht
mal, das macht 0,1% aus oder so, was sie da erzählt haben, ist natürlich totaler Blödsinn.
Das ist, wie wenn man sagt, Zombies macht nur 1% aus. Genau, das Survival Modus kommt
ja später. Das Spec Ops Missions Modus, der kommt ja, das ist auch das, das ist das,
was ich persönlich auch cool fand, bei MW2 und 3. MW2 habe ich mit dem Frisör richtig
gerne die Co-Op Spec Ops Mission gespielt. Aber ansonsten kennt noch einer die, kennt
noch einer die AC130 Mission aus MW2, also die Spec Ops Mission. Da musste ein Spieler,
da hat ein Spieler hier AC130 und ein Spieler war auf der Erde und wenn ein Spieler gestorben
ist, war vorbei. Das war eigentlich ziemlich cool für Co-Op. Das war eigentlich ziemlich
cool. Ich meine, das hat einen kleinen Teil vom Game aus gemacht, aber es war doch dennoch,
es war das echt ein cooler Teil. Ich finde, eh in MW2 haben sie damals richtig, richtig
viel Zeug reingestopft. Da war für jeden irgendwas dabei. Ah, Lukizu, ich finde, Flag Ops 1 war
der beste. Wie teuer ist es eigentlich, den Nass zu bauen, fällt mir gerade so ein, nur
mit SSDs. Sagen wir mal, ich will einen, keine Ahnung, wir gucken einfach mal, was, was für
Terabyte SSDs gerade kosten. Ok, das ist schon ganz schön teuer. Ups, das ist schon ganz
schön teuer. Ich meine, ist ja bald Black Friday. Ja, aber da haben die die guten Sachen
hier nicht. Also ich meine, mit den Covo-Dingern geht es noch irgendwie, wobei die halt performancemäßig
nicht so gut sind wie die und theoretisch auch schneller kaputt gehen, aber da würde
ich mir keine Gedanken machen. Stell es doch mal Mindfactory zusammen. Es geht doch halt
darum, was die Platten kosten, also was die SSDs kosten. Also 4 Terabyte SSDs sind schon
echt teuer. Die sind schon ganz schön teuer. Also ich glaube nicht, dass ich das in nächster
Zeit machen kann. Eigentlich bräuchte es ja auch 8, gibt es schon 8 Terabyte, gibt es
schon 8 Terabyte SSDs? Nein, 4 Terabyte ist das größte. Na gut. 4 mal 1 Terabyte in Rate
0, das wäre wahrscheinlich billiger, ja. Aber ich habe daran gedacht, dass man beispielsweise
einen Rate 1 machen könnte aus 8 Terabyte SSDs, aber es gibt ja gar keine 8 Terabyte
SSDs. Oder man macht einen Rate 1 aus 4 Terabyte SSDs, da hat man so nur 4 Terabyte Speicher,
aber ziemlich schnell lesen. Gibt es 4 Terabyte NVMe? Ok, ne, da ist 2 Terabyte das größte.
Ach Mensch, das wäre nice, wenn ich einfach 5 SSDs in den Sauber klatscht, braucht keinen
Strom, ist saumäßig schnell. Problem ist auch, ist saumäßig teuer. Ja ich weiß, klar
es gibt große SSDs, aber das sind halt keine Consumer-Dinger, die sind halt übelst teuer.
Nichtschenk geblieben. Was kommen eigentlich noch für Games jetzt raus? Was kommen jetzt
eigentlich noch für Games raus? Also jetzt so. Upcoming. Gibt es da eine schöne Übersicht?
Ach Cyberpunk, kommt Cyberpunk schon raus? Oktober, also was kommt denn hier noch alles
Interessantes? Das wollte ich mir mal angucken. Das ist so ein bisschen RPG-mäßiges Rumgestellte,
das könnte sogar ganz nett sein. Outerlands? Ist Outerlands dieser Fallout 4 Verschnitt?
Ne, das ist was anderes. Wie hieß das? Wie hieß dieses Fallout-Ding? Scheiß vergessen.
Overwatch-Legend für die Switch, Alter. Der Switcher ist mittlerweile auch auf der Switch
angekommen. Nicht mal der Witcher, sondern der Switcher. Zombieladen braucht kein Mensch,
aber das braucht auch keiner. Blablabla, das ist irgendwie nicht sonderlich spannend,
was da rauskommt. LittleBigWorkshop, hat das was mit LittleBigPlanet zu tun? Ne, kann's
nicht sein, weil wenn's auf der PS4 rauskommt, äh wenn's auf dem PC rauskommt, kann's
nicht kein LittleBigPlanet sein. Ach, Outer Wilds, nicht Outer Worlds, das haben sie mich
debatet, ja. Alles nicht so interessant. Apex Legends, Bloodhorn. Warum ist Apex eigentlich
so abgekackt an Viewerzahlen? Das versteh ich nicht. Ich mein, guckt euch das. Ok,
jetzt Streams, gerade die zwei größten, dieses Stream. Ja ok, jetzt ist das an Viewerzahlen
ziemlich gut. Ähm, aber normalerweise, wenn man sich das anguckt, ist, ich mein, es gucken
475 Leute irgendwie in einem schwarzen Loch zu. Fuck. Ich will Viewers. Also Apex gucken
gerade richtig viel, aber die letzten Monate war Apex richtig am abkacken. Ähm, ist für
mich immer noch so mit das beste Battle Royale Game, ohne dass ich Battle Royale spiele.
Das ist eigentlich, aber so rein vom Gucken her, gefällt mir, gefällt mir Apex eigentlich
am besten. Moin, Soldier 5084. Ganz schön teuer. Ganz schön, ganz schön teuer hier die
ganzen SSD-Geschichten, das kann man vergessen. So, was kommt denn sonst noch so? So, das
nächstes, was mich interessiert, kommt World of Warfare raus. 25. Oktober, dauert nicht
mal lang. Übernächste Woche Freitag. Rest juckt mich nicht. Ach, hier kommt das. Pre-Order.
Das kommt auch am 25. Oktober raus, ok. Disney Classic Games Aladdin. Nein, juckt mich nicht.
Resident Evil 5, Resident Evil 6, nochmal für die Switch. Die Switch ist so die Remake-Tonne
irgendwie, wo alle noch mal, alle Spiele von allen letzten Generationen jetzt nochmal auf
der Switch rausbringen. Richtig. Ach, Death Stranding kommt ja am, stimmt das Game kommt
ja schon raus. Death Stranding ist bei mir im Kopf ein Game, wo es einmal im Jahr verwirrende
Trailer gibt und das Spiel nie erscheint. Aber ist ja gar nicht so, das kommt jetzt
ja raus. Da bin ich gespannt drauf, da bin ich gespannt drauf. Es kommt Dreaded Redemption
für den PC. Ich sag jetzt mal was Kontroverses, ja, geht mir am Arsch vorbei. Juckt mich,
juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Aber ich hab schon öfters gesagt, ich bin einfach nicht der,
nicht der große Open World Spiele Spieler. Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie eine ganz gute
Story haben, das kriegen die eigentlich immer hin bei Rockstar. Aber ich bin einfach kein
großer Fan von Open World Spielen. Deswegen, das einzige auf, magst du GTA? Nö mag ich
auch nicht. Das einzige Open World Spiel, was mir wirklich sehr gut gefallen hat, was
richtig Open World war, also neuere Open World Games. Das einzige richtige Open World Game,
was mir gefallen hat, war der Witcher. Also drei, die anderen, die eins und zwei waren
ja keine Open World. Witcher 3 hat mir richtig gut gefallen, aber auch nicht unbedingt der
Open World Aspekt, sondern die Main Kampagne war richtig gut, die DLC-Story war richtig
gut und was bei Witcher 3 wirklich auch gut war, ist, dass die ganzen Quests, die irgendwie
in der Welt verteilt waren, zum größten Teilen auch halbwegs interessant waren, zum
größten Teil, ja nicht alle. Aber es gab schon ein paar ganz coole Sachen, die eine
da mit dem Werwolf, kann mich auch irgendwie an so eine Quest erinnern, wo die Freundin
dann zum Werwolf wurde oder der Freund zum Werwolf, irgendwie sowas. Aber das war schon
okay, ja. Den richtigen, diesen richtigen Open World Aspekt daran haben wir nicht gebraucht
und ich finde auch, dass die Witcher Open World so ein bisschen, zumindest in den Dörfern
so ein bisschen, ein bisschen unfertig gewirkt hat. Die Leute standen da halt rum, die hatten
ihre drei Sprüche, die haben im Prinzip nichts großartig gemacht und es hat sich jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie angefühlt, als reitet man da durch den Dorf durch. Was halt richtig
geil gemacht von Witcher 3 waren die größeren Städte. Das war halt ebenso, er quennt auch,
ja. Das war halt übelst geil. Naja, aber. Hallo Max, endlich mal ein Livestream von dir,
sehe nach sieben oder acht Jahren YouTube. Aber ja, nice. Ja, hast du halt, aber eigentlich
sind übelst langweilig den Livestream erwischt, weil ich hab keine Ahnung, was wir genau machen.
Wir schwätzen einfach. Also ihr könnt mich alles fragen, was ihr fragen wollt, dass wir
Gesprächs, Gesprächsstoff haben, ja. Es gibt jetzt irgendeine Free to Play Version von Pupke mit
minimaler Grafik. Solltet ihr nicht mal drauf gucken, dass ihr Game überhaupt richtig läuft.
Ey Leute, ich hab letztens wieder. Ich hab letztens wieder mal zehn Minuten. Das könnte
das gewesen sein, das könnte das hier sogar gewesen sein. Ich hab letztens mal wieder zehn
Minuten von irgendeinem PUBG Pupke Cup geguckt, ne. Kann sein, als es das war. War das jetzt
irgendwie erst vor ein paar Tagen? Dann ist was anderes. Zumindest, ich sag euch Leute,
ähm, übelst langweilig. Also das ist echt kein eSport Game. Pupke eSport, es ist so langweilig.
Da gewinnt das Team am Ende mit zwei Kills. Die spawnen, liegen rum, hoffen, dass der Circle
irgendwie an der richtigen Stelle kommt. Und, ähm, campen dann weiter rum. Und am Ende killen sich
dann die Leute gegenseitig und ein Team campt weiter. Und das killt dann die letzten zwei
Leute und hat gewonnen. Ganz merkwürdig. Wie hast du eigentlich Internet, wenn du Unity Media
hast, wie so funktioniert doch wunderbar. Gehts?
Ähm, das würde ich dann eher mathematisch angehen. Ich würde mir die Menge der Haare angucken und,
ähm, dann kannst du einfach eine Menge an Haaren bilden, die weiß sind und eine Menge an Haaren
bilden, die schwarz sind. Und dann musst du das gar nicht, ähm, so beantworten. Oder hast
trotzdem die Antwort. Schon mal Kaffee gegessen? Ähm, nee. Keine Ahnung. Also nicht wissentlich.
Also nicht wissentlich aus irgendeiner Dose oder so. Und was ist mit Milka Kühen? Die sind CGI
alt mittlerweile. Weil die Kühe nicht mehr einfärben dürfen. Schau mal StreamPie angeschaut, nö.
Was ist das? Was ist StreamPie? Wo soll man Link schicken? Benutzt du einfach nur LibreOffice?
Ich benutze gar kein Office. Ach, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich, das Video, Patrick. Ich benutze
gar kein Office. Ich habe LibreOffice installiert, aber verwenden tue ich es nicht. Hehehe. Abstörung
bei Unity Media. Stream läuft aber seit Aufruf. Also, ich habe Unity Media geflamed auf Twitter
und ich habe jetzt DualStack Lite gekriegt, auch wenn sie mich da wieder ein bisschen gescampt
haben bei der ganzen Geschichte. Aber es funktioniert jetzt und ich mache da auch nichts mehr, alles
gut. Apex ist mega hype in den USA, aber sonst nirgends, okay. Ich wollte das auch mal
spielen. Vielleicht ist das echt ein Game für mich. Hast du den neuen Film Joker gesehen?
Nein. Gibt es ihn denn schon auf einschlägigen Sicherheitskopie? Gibt es ihn schon als Sicherheitskopie
irgendwo? Nein, Oldrade HC2 ist wirklich der günstige Optacore Einplatinencomputer. Ja,
und vor allem, der ist schon 3 Jahre alt oder so. Ich habe jetzt ja das Teil hier drüben
stehen als TV-Server, den da mit Platte drin und das funktioniert wunderbar. Das funktioniert
echt richtig gut, viel besser als ich gedacht habe. Einfach hier eine USB-Dual-Tuner dran,
2TB WD-Green-Platte eingesteckt, die ich noch da hatte. Wir haben es ja im Stream gemacht.
Fertig, easy, läuft wunderbar. Yeratiel, warum bist du ein Jahr offline? Wenn du gekündigt
hast, kannst du einfach einen neuen Vertrag abschließen. Wie ist das jetzt in Apex? Hat
es jetzt einen Solo-Modus? Wobei ich sagen muss, ich finde, irgendwie macht es das Game
ja auch schon ein bisschen aus, dass es eben Trio ist. Das ist ja auch mit den Flagen und
Respawn ein bisschen drauf ausgelegt. Ab jetzt auf dem Pi Zero TV hat er ein installiert
DVPC. Ja, das ist richtig nice. Ich meine, ich habe es auf der Kiste, die ist eine ganze
Ecke stärker als den Raspberry Pi Zero. Zero ist ja ein ARM V6 Single Core. Der Raspberry
Zero hat halt nix im Endeffekt. Da ist der hier schon ein bisschen schneller. Und der
läuft, läuft echt gut. Gab es eigentlich schon ein Update zu Fiverr? Ja, ist alles fertig
seit einem Monat schon. Ich habe bloß immer noch das Video nicht gemacht. Fiverr ist seit
einem Monat schon fertig. Also einer hat was geliefert, das taugt eigentlich nicht wirklich
was und die anderen wollten mehr Geld oder haben abgesagt oder haben gesagt, sie können
es nicht mehr haben. Wie hielst du beim O-Trill mit AES aus? Ganz okay. Ich glaube, der hat
theoretisch Krypto Extensions, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das aktiviert ist, ob das funktioniert.
Das müsste man mal ausprobieren. Können wir jetzt mal, könnte ich jetzt eigentlich
machen? Machen wir mal Vmware an. Ich gucke mal, wie schnell das geht. Ich muss nur mal
nachgucken, wie das funktioniert hat. Ach das, okay, das ist cool. Das muss ich mir mal
angucken. Eine robuste Alternative zum Elgato Stream Deck. Also im Prinzip hat einer mein
Meme Board genommen und hat das mal ordentlich gebaut. Hast du eigentlich mal Zertifikate
wie C10A gemacht? Ja, aber das ist schon ewig ausgelaufen. Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal
an. Was kann das denn? Raspberry Pi? Was macht das denn? Features. Wie das ist alles?
Wie wäre es mit Screenshots? Okay, wir gucken uns mal das Video an. Warum gibt es kein Donation
Button, weil Tippy Stream irgendwie kaputt ist und ich habe es wieder rausgeschmissen?
Aber du kannst mir natürlich gerne einfach einen Prime-Sub dalassen. Huge Kamerarbeit,
fast so gut wie bei mir. Bsreelight, Tripsprime, Dankeschön, Poggas.
Eine Alternative, die kann, Kontrolle OBS. So wie das es gerade gemacht hat. Nun, ich bin
hier um euch zu sagen, es gibt eine Alternative. Eine große Reveal. Meine Damen und Herren,
ich bin stolz auf Stream-Pi. Ich glaube, der hat wirklich mal ein Meme-Board genommen
und einfach mal ordentlich gebaut. Also nein, der hat nicht meins genommen, aber der hat
die Idee im Endeffekt genommen und mal weitergedacht und ordentlich gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob
ich das verwenden kann. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob ich das verwenden kann.
Weißt du, was sinnvoll wäre bei diesen ganzen Videos, immer wo die Leute ihre Projekte vorstellen?
Einfach ein 1-Minute-Video machen, wo man es in Action sieht und ein paar interessante
Features. Weil so habe ich keinen Plan genau, was es ist. Ist es ein Tablet? Ein Tablet
irgendwie. Ja, das ist von der Idee genau so. Das ist im Prinzip fast das Gleiche, wie
ich hier mit meinem Board gebaut habe. Nur wahrscheinlich ein bisschen durchdachter als
ich. Was genau ist so schlimm, dass es sehr wir-programmiert ist an vielen Stellen? Ich
meine, exakt das kann man mit meinem Tool genauso machen. Im Prinzip ist das genau das
Gleiche. Das geht auch auf einem Tablet. Nur, dass ich GIF-Animationen kann und dass
ich Sounds kann. Und sogar MP4-Sounds, also Audio-Spur in MP4-Videos oder Text-to-Speech.
Und Touch Ui geht hier auch drauf. Zeit voraus. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass seins ein bisschen
besser durchdacht ist als meins. Es ist eine ziemlich hässliche Oberfläche, muss ich jetzt
mal sagen. Ist deins auf Github? Meins ist auf Github, allerdings eine uralt Version.
Die allererste Version, die ich gebaut habe, ist auf Github. Aber die kann halt keine Animation,
die kann keinen Text, die kann keinen Sound, die kann einfach nur Bilder overlayen. Dafür
ist sie ziemlich simpel. Da ist eigentlich nicht wirklich viel, was man verstehen muss
dran. Okay, was kann das Ding noch? Wolltest du dich noch mal fragen, ob du bei TV einen
beiden Tuner an eins oder zwei IPs gebunden hast? Keine Ahnung, ich habe gar nichts extra
gebunden irgendwie. Ich habe es auch im Stream sogar gemacht. Okay, da kannst du auch Skripte
hinterlegen und so. Das macht es natürlich schon interessanter. Wieso pusht du keine
neue Version, weil die kacke sind? Weil ich mich teilweise schäme für die eklichen Sachen,
die ich hier verzapft habe. Das will ich so nicht veröffentlichen. Hätte er nicht mal
ein bisschen gestrafteres Video dazu machen können? Aber damit kannst du OBS fernsteuern,
das kann man mit meinem Tool natürlich nicht. OBS fernsteuern kann man natürlich mit meinem
Zeug nicht. Das Einzige, das ist viel mehr als das, was ich gebaut habe. Wie gesagt,
meins kann nur Bilder overlayen und Text-to-Speech-Text machen oder koreanisch Text-to-Speech machen
oder Bilder und Sound. Also, meins kann nur Audio-Video-Zeug und der hat ja wirklich
komplette OBS-Fernsteuerung gebaut, die man da drauf legen kann. Programmierst du eigentlich
auch auf der Arbeit ab und zu seltener als mir lieb ist? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Job,
da hab ich Job oder Ausrufezeichen Beruf. Ich weiß gar nicht, wir haben ein Kommando
dafür, da hab ich versucht mal zu ergleiten auf der Arbeit, zu treiben. Nein, mein Meme-Bot
benutzt kein OBS, der macht Windows-Overlay, dass ich selbst sehe. Okay, jetzt hab ich
gecheckt, was der meint, aber das ist schon eine ganze Ecke Advanster, was der gebaut
hat, als was ich gebaut hab. Außerdem, ich seitens in Java, das widerstrebt mir natürlich
so ein bisschen. Ja, cheat, ich mach gefühlt mehr Code-Reviews als selber programmieren,
das stimmt. Das stimmt, leider, ja. Paints-Champ, Java, Paints-Champ. Können wir mal ein bisschen
gucken? Können wir mal ein bisschen gucken, ich will mir keinen Java-Source-Code angucken.
Dabei ist die Java und die Sharp-Source-Code gar nicht so großartig. Kannst du mal erklären,
wie man mein altes Meme-Bot nutzt? Das ist ganz einfach. Du gehst einfach hier hin und
lädst dir das einzige Release-Wasser, das es gibt, runter. Ja, Meme-Bot Excel. Und dann
machst du, was hier als Anleitung drin steht. Das ist ziemlich simpel, aber halt nicht sonnerlich
advanced, ja. Oh Gott, Java, Alter, wenn ich es sehe. MonkaS. Aber ehrlich gesagt,
es sieht halt schon ähnlich aus, wie meinst du die Sharp-Zeug? Was ist denn das, sind das
Attribute oder was ist das? Füchsemel? Scheiße, das Fuck-XML, der Sache würde ich zustimmen.
What the fuck? Warum muss der sich um irgendwelche Threat-Management kümmern bei Buckle-Click-Events?
Boah, sieht das eklig aus, Alter. Oh, boah. Hä? Main. Ja, anscheinend habe ich noch nie
was mitgemacht, keine Ahnung. Fuck-XML-Loader. Load. Aber ich muss sagen, seine Benamung ist
zumindest schon mal ganz gut. Er hat keine Factory-Manager-Manager-Class-Factory-Creator-Observer-Factory-Manager. Main, okay, was startet
das denn jetzt hier? If-F-XML. Igitt! Igitt! Das ist nicht wirklich das Frontend, was man
in XML deklariert, oder? Da ist ja diese XML-Geschichte noch richtig hübsch dagegen. Ich weiß, XML ist
auch XML, aber ein bisschen kurz und knackiger. Und ich finde XML auch schon kacke. Also an
der ganzen WPF-Geschichte geht mir XML am meisten auf den Keks. Da macht's QML viel
besser. QML ist, finde ich, die schönste Interface-Beschreibung. Habe ich mal ein Beispiel. Habe ich mal ein schönes
Beispiel. Ja, sowas hier. Das ist doch schon mal viel besser lesbar als irgendwelche XML-Crap.
Also QML, finde ich, ist die schönste Interface-Beschreibungssprache, die man von Hand schreibt, wohlgemerkt. Wenn man
über irgendwelche GUI-Designer macht, wie beispielsweise diesen Windows-Forms-Designer, der macht ja
unter der Haube auch Spaghetti-Code, aber da macht man es halt immer mit einem Designer.
Aber QML schreibt man halt von Hand. Und das ist richtig schick. Also QML, finde ich, ist
das die schönste. Ach, du meinst, das ist auch so ein Designer? Okay, dann ist okay.
Also, wenn das mit einem Designer erstellt wird, ist okay, wenn man den Mist nicht von
Hand schreiben muss. Dann ist es in Ordnung. Dann macht man das einfach in seinem Designer
und muss sich den Source-Code nie dazu angucken. Das ist okay. Ich dachte, man schreibt den
Mist von Hand. Ich mein, guck beispielsweise mal hier mein, das XML-Gegenstück von mir,
das ist jetzt halt handgewurstet. Das sieht jetzt auch nicht viel schöner aus, ja. XML
ist halt immer scheiße. Oh, es gibt sogar Arm-Bills. Aber auch in Java. Geh weg. Schau
mal SQF von Bohemia an, da musst du mir mal einen Linkshoot zuschicken. Kannst du bitte
aufhören oder ich reporte dich. Mit was? Du meinst mit XML angucken? Ja, YAML ist mir
persönlich auch deutlich lieber als XML, wobei ich mittlerweile schon wieder einen Schritt
zurückgegangen bin. Ich verwende auch kein YAML mehr. Ich verwende eigentlich für alles
irgendwelche JSON-Config-Files, wenn es geht. YAML hat ja so mit Rails so richtig den Durchbruch
gehabt damals. Aber ich mag Klammern. Okay, was soll ich mir angucken, das da? Was ist
das überhaupt? SQF? Ist das für den Armor Level Editor oder wie? Was ist das? Das sieht
fast aus wie Erlang. Oder? Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Erlang. Also genauso hässlich
wie Erlang. SQF-Example. Gucken wir mal. Nein. Ach, das ist die Armor Scripting Engine. Okay,
Armor ist schon so ein Spiel, was nicht ordentlich läuft. Da wird die Armor Scripting Engine
auch nicht besser sein. Gehen wir noch am Fernsehbauen? Nö. Okay, das sieht schon
hardcore eklig aus. Das hat ein bisschen was von Windows-Batch. Das hat was von CMD-Batch
irgendwie. Ach, nee, nee, nee, hör mal auf. Das ist ja eklig. Das will man nicht haben.
Nee, ich bin nicht mehr am Fernsehbauen. Wo sind wir eigentlich gerade stehen geblieben
vorher? Das ist schrecklich. Ja, das ist echt schrecklich. Okay, gucken wir mal, was
es da für neue Sachen gibt. Irgendwelche Steam-Games zu empfehlen. Ach, stimmt, wir
wollten eigentlich gucken, was sonst noch dieses Jahr für interessantes Zeug rauskommt.
Max, hast du schon den Ultra-Gaming-PC gesehen, den ich auf Discord geschickt hab? Nee.
Welchem Channel hast du den geschickt? Können wir uns jetzt mal angucken? Gucken wir uns
mal Gaming-PC Setup an. Rails, was ist das nochmal? Ja, das ist so eine Sache, die man
2005 verwendet hat. Wenn du Java nicht magst, Marcelo von Kotlin, würde ich jederzeit Java
vorziehen. Kotlin hat sich so das Beste aus allem geschnappt. Welchem Channel hast du
das gepostet? Allgemein. Ach, der da. Okay, zeig's mal her. The fuck? Who buys that?
Fx3300? 8300? Was soll das sein? Von 2009 oder was? Was kostet's? 1000 Euro! Okay.
Das Gerät ist mit einem sehr schnellen Acht-Kern-Prozessor. So wie mit schnellen 8GB. War das schon DDR3?
Nee, das war noch DDR2, oder? Von Shinobi. Von Shinobi ist das. Heißt die eine Ba-
ja ja nicht auch Shinobi? Oder Shibune oder so? Die ganzen Weebs unter uns wissen das
bestimmt. Shinobu, Shinobu, genau, Shinobu. Irgendwie so. Okay. 8GB Markenarbeitspeicher
ausgestattet. Jetzt haben sie sich auch noch Encoding-Fails. Auch noch Encoding-Fails.
Dass man das im Jahr 2019 noch hat. Arbeiten sie in Ruhe ohne störende Lüfter. Oh, das
leises Netz hat und hat einen geregelten Lüfter. Ui, was das alles hat. Sehr schnelles GT710.
Ai ai ai, das ist ja absolut high-end. Warum hat das Ding überhaupt so gute Bewertung?
Shinobibi. Den Shop müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken auf Amazon. Okay, Fyte, die Typen
gibt es ja wirklich. Ultra, Ultra-8-Kern. Ist das denn, sag mal, ernsthaft jetzt? Warum
verkaufen die noch, warum verkaufen die denn? Was ist denn das für eine beknackte Kombi,
Alter? Ach so. Dass das überhaupt startet in Kombination. Ich meine, von wann ist die
CPU 2009? Oder 11? Release, release, release. 2009, 2009, 2009, 2009, 2009, 2009, 2009, 2009,
2012. Ich aber trotzdem. Ich meine, das ist eine 8 Jahre alte CPU, die wohlgemerkt damals
schon gesackt hat. Und außerdem ist das, glaube ich, gar kein 8-Kerner, oder? Das war
doch damals kein echten 8-Kerner. Das war doch diese... Ich kann mich ja schon gar nicht
mehr richtig dran erinnern. Turbo. Okay, wo ist der PC, den du gesehen hast? Den gucken
wir uns jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer an. Wenn ich den Namen sehe, da habe ich jetzt
irgendwie diesen komischen Aya-ya-Ausschnitt im Kopf. Shinobuni. Aya-ya? So. Amazon Choice.
Moment, wir gucken jetzt mal was anderes. Wir gucken jetzt mal was, und zwar die Bewertung
müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken. Wichtig ist, von wann die ersten Bewertungen sind,
kann man auch älteste zuerst machen? Älteste zuerst? Nein. Geht natürlich nicht Amazon.
Amazon. Sortieren nach neueste zuerst. Ich glaube es nicht. Warum gibt es kein Paging
mehr für Kommentare? Meine Güte, Alter. Wie mich Webdesign 2019 abfuckt. Wie mich Webdesign
2019 abfuckt, das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen. Ich will einfach nur sehen, wann
der älteste Kommentar her ist. Warum geht das nicht? Oder bin ich einfach nur zu dumm?
Webdesign 2019, ey. Wie lange darf ich das jetzt machen? Drei Stunden, oder? Ach, hier.
Okay. Also die erste, die erste Rezension ist von Mitte 2018. Das heißt, die verkaufen
wirklich einen PC von vor, sagen wir mal, acht Jahren, sieben Jahre, einen PC von vor
sieben Jahren, der vor sieben Jahren noch nicht mal gut gewesen wäre. Das war die Zeit,
wo AMD überhaupt nicht mithalten konnte. Boah, wupp wupp wupp geht mir auf. Bin vollends
positiv überrascht. Alle Spiele laufen bei höchster Auflösung. Also entweder ist das
der übelste Kacknoob oder er ist bezahlt. Ich hätte beim Kauf von Einzelkomponenten
wesentlich mehr bezahlt. Das bezweifle ich. War ganz davon abgesehen. Natürlich ist der
scheiß teuer. Das gibt es ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr. Mehr als Defekthexe. Was
ist Defekthexe? Okay, dann müssen wir uns die Bewertung mal angucken. Was ist eine Defekthexe?
Ich hab keine Ahnung Leute, ich hab keinen Schimmer. Es gibt eine Seite, wo man Fake-Bewertungen
filtern kann. Okay, wie machen die das? Das hab ich noch nie. Oh, das ist ja cool. Was
ist das? Review-Matter. It's a tool analyzing reviews on Amazon. I understand. Copy-Paste-Product-Url. Ja, geht wahrscheinlich nur auf Englisch,
okay. Okay, das sieht sehr vertrauenserwürdig aus.
Die haben die Produkte getauscht irgendwie, aber die anderen Produkte waren genauso kacke.
Okay, also was schreiben denn die Leute? 102 Personen fanden das hilfreich. Die am höchsten
bewertete kritische Rezession ist, zweimal ein beschädigtes Gerät erhalten. Mehr als
Defekthexe. Ich hab immer noch keine Ahnung, was er uns sagen will mit Defekthexe. Link
auf Discord geschickt. Vor allem hat er auch noch so ein hässliches Gehäuse dabei. Okay,
wir müssen jetzt mal die Kommentare durchlesen. Was schreiben die Leute denn alles? Kann man
drei Monitore anschließen? Moment. Ja, der hat recht, der Typ. Leider sehr enttäuschend.
Ich meine, wer das glaubt, ja. Wer das glaubt. Was? Defekthexe? Diese Seite? Ernsthaft, es
gibt ne Seite, die Defekthexe heißt. Okay, das hat damit aber glaub ich nix zu tun. Alter,
die Musik. Oh, Grip. Oh. Kann ich mal wieder nicht entscheiden, ob's laut oder leise sein
soll. Geldabzock ist statt Gamingwunder. Ist leider überhaupt kein Gaming-PC, wie angegeben.
Ach, eher ein schlechter Witz. Oh, der hat sogar ne 1060. Veraltenes Board, schlechter
RAM, langsamer Festplatte, schlechte CPU. Noch nichtmal für CSGO ist das ausreichend.
CS will so viel FPS wie irgendwie nur möglich. GTA V ruckeln, das heißt schon was. GTA V
läuft eigentlich fast überall. Halbwegs, halbwegs. Gut zum anderen. Ja, die Rezession
ist zwei Tage alt. Kompletter Dreck. Besser 500 Euro mehr ausgeben und einen guten und
zukunftssicheren PC ausgeben. Für 500 Euro kann er sich nen besseren PC kaufen aktuell.
All die Musik. Witz. 7, 7 Cent. Dankeschön. Schlagschade. Gut. Magst du die Fallout-Reihe?
Ich hab die neuen nicht mehr gespielt, aber an sich schon, ja. Oh, ich hab was, ich hab
was übersehen, Leute. The Reezes. Bist du noch am Start? Nur mit einem echten Sub ist
mein LQ ins unermessliche gestiegen, Pfeil Pferd. Ja, hoffe ich mal, hoffe ich. Und mit
jedem Monat, mit jedem Monat wird's noch mehr. Wie wär's mit PC-Empfehlungen zu Weihnachten?
Ja, wenn Hardware-Rat da Bock hat, können wir wieder was machen. Das sind doch, das
sind doch Fake-Reviews, oder? Oder ist das, oder sind die Leute wirklich einfach nur dämlich?
PC scheint leise zu sein, funktioniert bei Spielen sehr flüssig. Nein. Wenn man Candy
Crush spielt vielleicht. Der PC hat alles, was man benötigt. Wichtig war, dass er das
Windows Office schon hatte. Oh, wichtig, natürlich ist das Windows Office enorm wichtig. Power
Point wäre nicht schlecht gewesen, kann man aber noch installieren. Alter, die Gnoobs,
ey. Top PC zum Top Preis, sehr guter PC. Nein, ist er nicht. War auch Activirus dabei,
ja. Norton Internet Security Suite bestimmt. Michi, Stufe 1, Dankeschön, Poggers. Ähm,
ich habe nur die Grafikkarte gewechselt, den Arbeitsspeicher und eine SSD, alles spielbar.
Moment, der hat auch noch richtig Geld reingesteckt in den PC. Ich habe nur die Grafikkarte gewechselt,
den Arbeitsspeicher und eine SSD, das heißt, der hat eigentlich alles ausgetauscht, was
noch irgendwie, was, oh Mann. Sowas gibt es, ich wusste nicht, dass es eine GTX 1030 gibt.
Sehr guter PC, schönes Gehäuse. Battlefront Apex Legends, na gut, die Dinger laufen auch
überall gut, aber ich bezweifle, dass die wirklich richtig gut laufen und wenn schon
liegt es da dran, dass eine 1060 dafür ganz okay ist. Ähm, mit Unschlapp, die Leute sind
so hängen geblieben, warum? Stimmt. Ah, jetzt verstehe ich, dass die Skamasen.
Den PC gibt es mit einer, nö, machen sie nicht. Sie haben mir das hier halt alles irgendwie
zusammengefasst, aber es ist alles, alles die gleiche Kack-CPU. So, und der andere,
der für tausend Euro, Alter, tausend, fucking, tausend Euro, tausend Euro für acht Jahre
für acht Jahre. Alter. Was ist dieses Wuppwuppwupp, das ist ja ätzend heute. Okay, wir gehen
jetzt mal auf Anfang zurück, gucken von wann die erste Bewertung ist. Okay, die Leute schätzen
das hier wirklich richtig ein. PC-Gehäuse leicht beschädigt. Internet G-Data lässt
sich nicht aktivieren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das ein negativer Punkt ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Es war nur ein Grafik-Chip undenkbar. Ah ja. Was möchte er uns sagen? Es war nur ein Grafik-Chip.
Er will uns nicht undenkbar sagen. Erkennbar? Erkennbar? Meint er den RAM-Riegel? Erkennbar?
Es war nur ein RAM-Riegel erkennbar? Will er uns sagen, dass das, dass da nur ein RAM-Riegel
drin ist? Es war nur ein RAM-Riegel erkennbar? Ja, es ist auch nur ein RAM-Riegel. Und weiter?
PC-Spiel in Ultra. Wow, auf mittleren Einstellungen, 25 FPS. Krasse Gaming-PC. Kack-W. Da können
wir wirklich mal Kack-W verwenden heute. Wow, in mittleren 25 FPS. Das ist schlecht. Ja,
die On-Board-GPU von der aktuellen CPU wäre besser. Kannst du mal auf Anker-Mann die PCs
bewerten? Was ist Anker-Mann? Ist Anker nicht so ein China-Hersteller von USB-Hubs und Zeug?
Okay. Warum man niemals einen PC bei Amazon kaufen sollte? Okay, was haben wir denn hier
noch drin? Insane Scam, okay. Okay, was ist Anker-Mann? PC-Systeme. Was soll ich da jetzt
zu sagen? Okay, also was schreiben die Leute denn hier sonst noch Tolles? Hilfe! Da sieht
man mal, dass tatsächlich hier mit Leute scamaßt werden. Die denken sich, sie kaufen wirklich
einen geilen Gaming-PC und dann ist es der... Ich meine, es ist in Deutschland nicht verboten,
das zu verkaufen. Muss man auch mal ganz klar sagen. Also, der darf diesen Kram hier verkaufen.
Ob man ihn als Ultra-Gaming-PC anpreisen darf, ist was anderes. Lieferung war schnell, optisch
und technisch 100%. Der Typ hat wirklich sich diesen PC für 1000 Euro gekauft, ich glaube
es nicht. PC langsam. Bewertung bezahlt. Okay, das ist jetzt gekauft.
Das kann nicht sein, dass es Leute wirklich gut finden. Angeblich soll der Prozessor den
Turbo unterstützen, aber er funktioniert... Welcher Turbo? Das ist nur ein PC, da war nichts
mit Turbo. Ein Ryzen 5 der zweiten Genre hat mehr Leistung als... Der Vergleich ist jetzt
ein bisschen komisch, aber okay. Der meint wahrscheinlich die GPU. Ist beim Ryzen überhaupt
eine GPU drinne? Das ist immer so wenig, kenn ich mich aus mit aktuellem Zeug. Ihr seid
doch Verbrecher aus Ursemia. Ja, das stimmt schon. Okay, hier haben es die Leute wenigstens
gecheckt. Ne, ne, ne. Das sieht doch jetzt halbwegs normal aus. Ich meine, natürlich
viel zu teuer im Endeffekt. Das ist aber nicht so ein Crap wie das andere, was wir
gesehen haben. Ich meine, das ist natürlich viel zu teuer für so was hier. Denkst du
der HP Microserver Gen 10 ist brauchbar für 12 VMs zu hosten, die Linux im Idle-Betrieb
fahren. Cheat125 schickt mir mal eine Link zu dem Sauber, den ihr kaufen wollt, da kann
ich ihr das sagen. Aber in der Regel ist fast alles schnell genug, um 12 VMs im Idle zu
hosten. Nächste Mal die Antwort, please. Welche? Welche Antwort? Okay, Moment, ich
guck sie mir mal kurz an. Der da. Ähm, also die Dinger sind übrigens immer, die sind
ziemlich gut. Die kann man an sich empfehlen, wenn man einfach was Fertiges haben will,
was was taugt. Das ist echt nicht schlecht, die Teile. Okay, was ist denn da drinnen?
Specifications, ein Opteron X300, was ist denn das? Ist das was Neues, ist das was Altes?
Ist das, ist das, ist das die, ist das ein Ryzen Abkömmling? Keine Ahnung von. Ah nee,
Jaguar ist das noch. Ja, mit wieviel RAM willst du den kaufen? Mit wieviel RAM ist deiner?
Das reicht dicke, um 12 Idle VMs zu hosten. Vorab kein Ding. 16G, jaja, easy, reicht
das, easy. Linux Idle, den Dinger, den gibste 256 MB RAM und gut ist. Das reicht, das reicht
dicke, für 12 Idle. Aber wohlgemerkt Idle, die ab und zu mal ein bisschen was machen,
aber du kannst, also, warum willst du überhaupt 12 Linux VMs hosten? Also, vielleicht kannst
du es nicht irgendwie anders losen? 12 Idle VMs hört sich irgendwie so, weiß nicht, was
hast du denn vor? Eine VM per Service, vielleicht kannst du einfach einen Container per Service
machen, das wäre noch deutlich ressourcensparender. Ein Container per Service braucht im Endeffekt
gar nichts. Meinst du Home Assistant und weitere Dienste? Web Server, was ist denn Bad? Web Server,
auf einem Home Server ist Overkill und nicht Energiesparen. Die Boards sind ganz gut. Nö,
das ist okay, kann man machen. Guck mal kurz in das Video rein, da zeigt ein Typ die Seiten
in Australien nehmen. Welches Video, Leute? Ihr wisst, ich bin beim Chat manchmal nicht
so ganz, ihr müsst versuchen die Comments, wenn ich da irgendwas mir angucken soll, die
so möglichst komplett zu verfassen, wo das alles drin ist. Ich kann nicht immer drei
Comments zusammensuchen, ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, auf was sich das bezieht. Aber
fertig PCs waren noch nie günstig, das stimmt, deswegen machen wir mal ein bisschen Werbung.
Die Dinger kann man sich holen. Die Dinger kann man sich holen. Was hat er denn aktuell?
Zeig mal her. Was hat er denn aktuell? Comments zusammengebaut mit installiertem Windows zu
Hause. Zu Hause an. Einfach anschließend loslegen, sehr gut konfiguriert. Was kriegen wir denn
hier für 399 Euro? Oh, siehe da, das Ding kostet nun ein Viertel von dem anderen und
ist in allen Belangen viel, viel besser. Was ich mich ja frage ist, wie er das mit dem
Preis macht. Ich meine, das ist schon ziemlich günstig, was er da zusammenwurstet. Natürlich
ist es vielleicht noch ein Ticken günstiger, wenn ich das selbst baue, aber er muss ja
noch was dran verdienen. Was noch mal ein Beispiel für SQF. Alter, was ist das?
Mir fällt keine Sprache ein, die ähnlich vergleichbar hässlich ist. Was ist das? Alter,
wie geht's? Das ist schlimmer als Paul. Mir fällt jetzt nichts Vergleichbares ein gerade.
Geh weg. Okay, was kann ich denn, wenn ich bei Hardwarerad richtig Kohle ausgeben will?
Den Horst Flock können wir kaufen. Den Horst Flock, wer ist denn der Horst Flock? Okay,
was kriegen wir bei Hardwarerad, wenn wir 3899 Euro ausgeben wollen? Zeig mal her.
Wer ist Horst Flock? Jeden Tag ein Video. Ich hab von Horst Flock noch nie was gehört.
Der immer so tut, als wäre er ein Rentner. Also so wie Wilhelm Kramer LP, oder was? Kennt
ihr noch jemand? Okay, also was kriegt man bei Hardwarerad für einen 3899 Euro PC? Schauen
wir mal. Einen i9. Okay, naja, schnellst hinter als CPU. So ein komisches Board, was so 3
Milliarden Sachen hat, was ich nicht brauch. 32G, 500G Samsung. Eine zweite 1TB SSD, okay.
Hätte man da nicht eine 2TB SSD nehmen können? Mann, das ist teuer, das Ding. Wilhelm Kramer
war doch Kollege, ja genau. Ich weiß, da gehen nur die Gerüchte. Ach okay, SLI, das
macht es teuer, das macht es teuer. Das allein sind ja schon mal 2500 Euro. Das allein sind
ja schon mal 2500 Euro oder 2600 Euro. 2x2080 Ti. Okay, SLI kommt mir nicht mehr in die
Tüte, was haben wir hier zu bieten? Das gleiche wahrscheinlich nur ohne SLI. So, ein bisschen
normalere Preise jetzt mal hier. Nehmen wir mal den da. Intel, 8700K. Hat der keine Ryzen
PCs? Ich dachte eigentlich, ne, wahrscheinlich die bisschen billigeren. Nehmen wir mal 1000
Euro, das ist eigentlich das, was ich aktuell für einen PC ausgeben würde. Da hat er einen
Ryzen drin. Aber warum hat er eigentlich noch die Ryzen 5er drin und auch keine Ryzen,
auch keine 3000er? Wahrscheinlich, weil die preisleistungsmäßig nicht so gut sind, ha?
Haltbestand. Na gut, ich mein, wenn es vom Preis her, wenn es vom Preis her sich besser
so lohnt, beziehungsweise eine bessere Grafikkarte einzubauen, dann ist das auf jeden Fall sinnvoller.
Aber da kann man nichts verkehrt machen, großartig, bei den PCs, wenn man was komplettes haben
will. Das hier liest sich auch nach Crap preisleistungsmäßig und das hier eh. Shinobi sei Dank, der Computer
läuft schnell und gut. Das ist auch wieder so ne Sellout Rezension. Meine Güte, die Leute.
Entweder sind das wirklich so Kacknoobs oder das ist einfach gekauft. Meine Güte, Alter.
Das ist was ein Kram, ey. Okay, oje, der Chat explodiert ja wieder hier. Ach so, das Video.
Das Video kann man zum Schluss gucken dann. Alter, was ist das für ein, für ein, ich
mein, das wupp, wupp, wuppt ja immer, aber Melodik ist das, ist das nicht wirklich gerade.
Ja, schon besser. Was, ein Link im Discord? Was?
Wonke S. Mit 2TB Mikro SST? War das nicht alles gefuckt? Das kann doch nicht, das kostet
gar nichts, oder? Kannst du erklären, was SLI für Vorteile hat und Nachteile hat? Naja,
der Vorteil bei SLI ist ganz klar, wenn dir eine Grafikkarte nicht ausreicht, weil du
irgendwie 8K, 4K, 120 FPS oder was auch immer machen willst, mit hohen Details, dann baust
dir noch eine zweite Grafikkarte da rein und du kriegst ein bisschen mehr Performance.
Du kriegst nicht doppelt so viel Performance, du kriegst, ich sag mal so 50, 40 bis 80%
mehr je nach Game Performance, aber die Nachteile sind, dass viele Games rumspacken auf SLI
Systemen, deswegen hat halt kaum noch eine SLI Systeme. Du hast irgendwelche Mikro-Ruckler
und es sackt einfach nur. Und viele Spiele haben auch keine gute SLI-Unterstützung mehr.
Das ist einfach outdated mittlerweile, SLI. Max, was meinst du, wie lange? Äh, wo sind
wir stehen geblieben? Max, was meinst du, wie lange dauert es, bis viele Programme und
Spiele auf Linux funktionieren und man wechseln kann, ohne auf Gaming-ETC zu verzichten? Wahrscheinlich
nie. Wahrscheinlich nie. Ich hab übrigens wieder jede Menge Subs verpasst, wir haben
ja einmal am Start den, ähm, oder besser gesagt, die Morchel 223 mit einem Prime-Sub
und dann haben wir Michael 50 Billiarden, Trillionen, was auch immer, resubscribed,
zwei Monate, huge, high IQ-Sub. Davor hatten wir noch Michi, aber den hab ich glaube ich
schon vorgelesen. Warum ist denn deine Twitch-Description nicht der Discord-Server? Das ist eine gute
Frage. Wenn mir einer meiner Mods kurz einen, äh, Invite-Link schicken könnte, der für
immer gültig ist, weil ich bin zu dumm sowas zu generieren, dann pack ich's in die Beschreibung
rein. Ja, ich wollte mir eigentlich noch ein paar Stellen anzeigen, zum Schluss jetzt angucken,
weil Gaming-PCs haben wir durch. Welches Terminal kannst du Windows 10 empfehlen? Also ich kann
dir zwei Sachen empfehlen. Einmal leg dir eine Linux-VM an und mach dein Zeug da drinnen,
das ist schon mal mein erster Tipp. Und wenn's unbedingt ein Windows-Terminal sein will,
dann kann ich dir hier nur den da empfehlen, den, der CMDR, der irgendwie meine Settings
vergessen hat vom letzten Mal. Der ist tausendmal besser als dieses Kack-Terminal, was bei Windows
kommt. Vielleicht ist in Zukunft das ganz gut, was Microsoft da gerade noch entwickelt.
Ähm, zum Thema Linux-Gaming kann ich eigentlich noch sagen, wenn wir, also eine, ich sag mal,
eine gute Sache könnte Google-Stadia tatsächlich machen. Äh, hier, du kannst den Linux-VM,
installier den Linux-VM, da hast du auch ein ordentliches Terminal. Besser als Windows-Crap.
Ähm, also eine Sache, für die Stadia tatsächlich sorgen könnte, aber wohl gesagt könnte ist,
dass manche Sachen besser auf Lilungs laufen. Ähm, weil der große Unterschied zwischen
den bisherigen Streaming-Anbietern, die es, also Gaming-Streamer-Anbieter, die es bisher
gegeben hat und Stadia ist ja, dass die Game, dass die Games explizit für Stadia angepasst
werden müssen. Also sprich, das sind keine VMs mit irgendwie, also das sind keine Windows-VMs,
wo irgendwie Grafikkarten durchgereicht werden oder so. Sondern, das sind, quasi, native
läuft das, wahrscheinlich haben die schon irgendwie gewisse Professionierungs-, Virtualisierungs-,
sonst was, Geschichte dahinter. Aber die Games müssen bei Stadia angepasst werden. Ich weiß
jetzt nicht, was dahinter läuft, aber ich bilde mir ein, ich hab irgendwo gelesen, es
wäre eine Linux. BSD ist in dem Bereich auch lustigerweise recht beliebt. Man darf nicht
vergessen, die Playstation läuft auf einem BSD, auf einem FreeBSD. Seit, ich glaub, seit
der Playstation 2 schon. Oder vielleicht sogar seit der Playstation 1. Ja, Morstl, das ist
nett von dir. Huge. Big IQ-Sub. Point Bugs. Ah, du wolltest auf Motroid Point IS ausprobieren.
Ja, kann ich schon machen. Wenn ich noch den, war das Cryptsetup Benchmark, was man machen
muss dafür? Ich glaub, Cryptsetup Benchmark ist das. Probieren wir es mal bei mir lokal
aus. Wie schnell ich verschlüsseln und entschlüsseln kann lokal bei mir auf dem Rechner, in der
VM. Und dann vergleichen wir das mal mit der Embedded-Kiste. Ah, dankeschön, Discord-Link,
den pack ich gleich mal in meine Channel-Beschreibung rein. Schauen wir mal. Ja, aber mal. Discord.
Discord. So, absenden. Also ich sollte jetzt eigentlich in meiner Channel-Beschreibung
einen Discord-Invite-Link haben. Ja, sollte funktionieren. Ok, also, so schnell sind wir
bei mir lokal. Und jetzt verbinden wir uns mal. Hab ich nicht mehr in der Historie drinnen.
Was, 123 oder 125 hier? Ok, wir gucken mal. Machen wir hier kurz auf, dass wir sehen,
was für Auslastung verursacht. Oh, ist nicht installiert. Installieren wir mal. Die Hoffnung,
dass die Fernsehaufnahmen nicht abkacken oder so. Hab keine Lust, von Windows 7 auf Windows
10 zu wechseln. Ja, die wird nichts anderes übrig bleiben. Stimmt, anderer Link. Ja,
das müssen wir nochmal anpassen. Das stimmt. Wir brauchen vom Nightbot den Link. Müssen
wir nochmal anpassen. Channels bearbeiten. Ok, also schauen wir mal. Crypt Benchmark.
Absenden. So, jetzt Paddles speichern. Ah, funktioniert. Ja, na. Also mit Verschlüsselung
ist auf dem O-Troid nicht sonderlich viel. Das liegt aber glaube ich da dran, dass der
Kernel, das ist ja ein Custom Kernel, den wir gebastelt haben hier. Das ist ja ein Custom
Kernel, den wir gebastelt haben. Und der hat wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend keinerlei
Crypto Extensions oder irgendwas drinnen. Es könnte aber auch sein, dass der keine
hat. Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher. Vielleicht hat er auch keine Crypto Extensions.
Kann sein. Kann sein. Weil, ich glaube, das hier ist das wichtige für Plattenverschlüsselung
und 83 MB Lesenschreiben. Ja, aber dann ist er halt volle Pulle ausgelastet. Habt ihr
mal geguckt, wie die CPU-Auslastung war, als ich das haben laufen lassen? Ach, das ist
ein Single Threaded oder was? Ah, nee, nee, nee, passt schon. Naja, also so geil mit Fähr-
und Endschlüssel ist da nix. Also da geht nicht allzu viel. Man müsste es mal ausprobieren.
Man müsste es mal ausprobieren, wie gut das wirklich funktioniert. Kann man jetzt schlecht
sagen. Funktioniert AES auf dem Pi mittlerweile? Ja, ich glaube, das liegt daran. Das ging
glaube ich, also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Aber ich glaube, das ging die ganze Zeit schon.
Das Problem war, dass die Encryption auf dem Raspberry Pi, also die Crypto Extensions in
der CPU nur auf dem 64-Bit-Betriebssystem funktionieren. Magst du welche Encryption- und Hashing-Methode
findest du aktuell am besten? Ich, ehrlich gesagt, ich fahre da so mit den normalen Standards
AES und Schale 256 und gut ist. Man muss es ja nicht unbedingt komplizierter machen als
nötig. Simple 2016 Twitch Prime, Dankeschön. IQ vom Chat wieder gestiegen. Was sagste zu
dem Deal hier? Mal gucken. Gaming PC Ryzen 5. Das sieht doch ganz ok aus. Was ist da
denn? Ah hier, da unten steht es. Das sieht ganz gut aus. Ich meine, es ist halt ein Ryzen
2, aber ganz ehrlich, das reicht auch. Ich würde mir zwar jetzt, wenn schon überhaupt,
ich würde mir einen Ryzen desktop PC bauen, wenn ich mir einen desktop PC bauen würde,
aber dann halt mit einem Ryzen 3. Aber das ist ok. 16G sind top. 2060, weil bei der Preiskategorie
ist das wahrscheinlich auch ganz ok, kommt ein bisschen auf die andere Seite. 256G SSD
ist halt wirklich osch klein. Bully Guard Internet Security, gut, braucht kein Mensch.
Guck mal, sogar ein Spiel dabei. Ja, das macht, der Eindruck ist ganz in Ordnung. Wobei ich
halt, wie gesagt, ich würde mir selbst was bauen. Ich würde mir wahrscheinlich irgendwas
bauen mit einem aktuellen Ryzen, noch ein bisschen schnelleren Grafikkarte und mit einer
größeren SSD, aber natürlich kommst du dann auch mit 700€ nicht mehr hin. Ich würde
aber wahrscheinlich 1000€ ausgeben und aktuell einen Ryzen rein machen, eine schnellere Grafikkarte
und eine größere SSD, dann bist du bei 1000€ und gut ist. Nein, also aktuell, wenn ich
mir einen desktop PC bauen würde, würde ich mir, zumindest so wie ich das zuletzt geguckt
habe, vielleicht hat Intel jetzt ja mittlerweile was Neues. Ich habe gelesen, dass die neuen
CPUs von Intel deutlich günstiger geworden sind, also die neuesten High-End CPUs von
Intel deutlich günstiger geworden sind als die Generation davor, aber ich würde wahrscheinlich
einen Ryzen bauen. Liegt zwischen dem Ryzen 2700X und 3700X, ich vermute mal nicht viel,
aber wir können ja mal gucken. Ein bisschen was dürfte schon sein, das hat sich da eigentlich
ganz gut was getan. Ja, 15%, 15% ist schon okay von einer Generation. Hat er nicht sogar
mehr Kerne? Ne, die haben beide 8 Kerne. Es ist halt rund um die bessere CPU. Preis-Leistungs-Mäßig
müssen wir mal gucken, was kosten da Kram so. Ja gut, deswegen hat Hardwarerat auch noch
die alten Ryzen drinne, weil die nicht so viel langsamer sind, aber viel billiger sind.
Die kosten nur die Hälfte. Naja, nicht ganz. Zwei Drittel. Weniger. Äh ne, was? Ne, quick
maths. So 40% oder so. Weniger.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was Intel jetzt noch treibt. Der neuere ist langsam getaktet.
Ja, das juckt doch nicht. Das juckt doch nicht. Rein auf Taktzahlen kannst du eh nicht gucken.
Selbst wenn, die Dinger laufen in der Regel eh höher als das was da angegeben wird.
Haben wir zuletzt bei dem Bauer, beim Auer angeguckt, die Boostgeschichten von den Ryzen
Dinger und dass die nicht so gut sind, wie er sich das erhofft hat. Hast du eine leichte
Möglichkeit, ohne was mit NPM oder Nodes zu machen, eine Python Datei über Javascript
auszuführen? What? Moment. Brauche keine Resultate von Python oder so. Es soll nur
die Python Datei exekuted werden. Moment. Du willst, du willst in Javascript quasi
nen Systemcall machen oder was? Du willst in Javascript quasi einfach nen Prozess starten,
wenn ich das jetzt mal so richtig verstanden hab. Naja, also Node wirst du auf jeden Fall
schon brauchen, weil du brauchst ja, du brauchst ja, du brauchst ja irgendeine Runtime. Und
ohne Node wird das nix. Oder ohne, sag mal, ohne irgendeinen Javascript, ohne irgendeine
Javascript Runtime wird das nix. Es mag da vielleicht irgendwelche leichtgewichtigeren
Sachen geben, aber irgendeine Runtime brauchste. Oh, das ist cool, Airworker. Aber das wird
wahrscheinlich nur ganz basic Sachen unterstützen, oder? Also wenn du einfach nur nen Programm
ausführen willst, also ist egal, ob es jetzt ein Python Programm ist, ein Go-Programm,
ein Shell-Script, dann machst du einfach, brauchst halt irgendwie ne Javascript Runtime
auf deinem System und sagst dann sowas, tja, in Python wärs jetzt irgendwie was OS-open
oder sowas. In Javascript ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, aber das ist halt auch ein bisschen
von der Runtime abhängig. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie man das in Node macht. Wahrscheinlich
auch sowas wie process, execute oder sowas. Tja, Leute, es ist 21 Uhr, äh, 55. Ich glaub,
ich muss gleich auf. Aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock aufzugehen. Aber ich
muss morgen wieder arbeiten gehen. Morgen KS. Ah, jetzt, ok, jetzt erzählt er, was er
haben will. Mein Raspberry Pi soll eine HTML-Seite haben, die einen Button auf der Seite hat.
Wird der gedrückt, soll eine Python angemacht werden. Mehr nicht. Ah, ähm, das hat mir
mit Javascript nichts zu tun. Du brauchst, du brauchst ein bisschen kleinzeitigen Javascript,
aber das ist viel einfacher. Ähm, du könntest, du könntest sowas wie, sowas wie Flask oder
so nehmen und einfach mini-Web-Server in Python starten, der, äh, deine Sachen ausführt.
Das ist, das ist super simpel hier, guck mal. Mehr brauchste nicht. Das bindest du einfach
in eine Python-Datei an, ein, und wenn einer diese, diese Url hier aufruft, dann wird diese
Funktion auf, ausgeführt. Und da kannst du natürlich dein, dein Python-Zeug drinne starten.
Da kannst du nämlich das Backern einfach in Python hosten, das macht's viel einfacher.
Und, ähm, für die Seite, für die Seite, die machst du entweder inline, schreibst du
hier, dann HTML rein. Ähm, oder aber du lässt irgendwie eine statische Seite da drüber
surfen. Das ist, das dürfte dann relativ einfach sein. Ah, so, so würde ich das wahrscheinlich
machen. Da würde ich nämlich einfach, ähm, in, in Python mein Backend starten. Ansonsten
könntest du das in jeder x-beliebigen anderen Sprache machen, da brauchst du kein Node
dafür oder so. Ja, das, du brauchst da wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich brauchst du da noch nicht
mal großartigen Javascript für. Machst n Button, Submit, Submit auf die, auf die Url
und gut ist. Da brauchst du nicht mal Javascript für, da brauchste, da brauchste eine, eine
Zeit, eins oder zwei Zeilen HTML. Kannste alles inline machen. Ja, also das ist glaub
ich recht easy damit zu bewerkstelligen. Preise von den neuen Intel-CPUs, ah, da gucken wir
jetzt noch mal schnell. Huge, äh, Quali. Beste Quali aller Zeiten hier. Was hat man
zu bieten? Oh, langsam, wenn die Intel-CPU-Namen aber auch wieder un, unleserlicher, könnte
es ja kaum sein, äh. Guck mal, die i3 haben jetzt hier vier Kerne, acht Threads, ähm,
ab dem i5 sind schon sechs Kerne, okay. Die sechs Kerne hab ich, bei mir noch ab dem i7
gekriegt. Commit lag, die stehen auf lag, wow. Moment. Warum kostet das 1000, ah, Moment.
Hi, ich hab mich verguckt. Ich hab mich verguckt. Es sind 129 Dollar. Ich wollt grad sagen,
die i3 kostet jetzt 1000 Dollar. Was ist da los? Ähm. Okay, die Preise sind okay. Die
sind jetzt wenigstens in Regionen, die konkurrenzfähig zu AMD sind. Aber die Bezeichnung ist ja schon
mal wieder wir, oder? I9, 10800F, 10900F, 10900KF. Also mit K ist ja wieder, äh, taktänderbar.
Was ist das, ein neuer Sockel wieder? Nee, nicht erst neu. Das ist tatsächlich wieder
ein neuer Sockel. Also Intel übertreibt's echt, ja. AMD schafft's irgendwie drei bis
vier Jahre oder so mit dem gleichen Sockel. Und Intel braucht quasi bei jedem geänderten
Register irgendwie gleich einen neuen Sockel. So nach dem Motto, oh wir haben da ein Transistor
an der anderen Stelle. Was machen wir denn da jetzt? Neuer Sockel. Was sonst? Intel macht
immer neuer Sockel. Ähm, Intel liebt ihre Pins. Die haben ja noch nicht mal mehr Pins.
Das ist es ja gerade. Die haben ja nur noch diese Pads zum Auflegen jetzt. Oder haben
Intel CPUs mittlerweile wieder Pins. Nee, ne? Diese Kontakte. Also was gibt's denn hier?
Also, okay, schauen wir mal. Vergleichbar, ich hab dann 8700K. Das ist vergleichbar mit
dem hier. Nur, dass ich jetzt zwei Kerne mehr kriegen würde. Takt hat sich nix geändert.
Ist exakt das gleiche wie bei mir. Also ich hab ja meine auch über Takt. Ich weiß gar
nicht wie viel. Ich glaub' meiner ist standardmäßig mit 4,5 gelaufen. Aber Takt ist exakt das
gleiche wie bei mir. So, dass alle mit 5,1 laufen. Es hat zwei Kerne mehr. Kostet aber
ein bisschen weniger als damals meiner. Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, fürs Spielen erscheint
mir der hier eigentlich noch mit am attraktivsten. Also zum Spielen muss ich sagen, gefällt
mir der hier eigentlich noch mit am besten. Der hat den besten Takt. Der hat ne gute Anzahl
an Kerne. Mehr brauchen wir fürs Spielen eh nicht. Der ist preisleistungsmäßig auch okay.
Ich mein, man könnte auch einfach den da nehmen. Bezahlt man 100€ mehr, 110€ mehr,
hat nicht wirklich viel niedrigeren Takt. Mit dem passenden Board und der passenden Kühlung
läuft der hier wahrscheinlich auch locker auf 4,8. Der ist auch nicht schlecht. Was ist
denn da bei AMD vergleichbar? Der 3800? 8 Kerne oder 3800? Ne, müssen wir noch ein
höher gehen. Ja, das ist ungefähr der vergleichbare. Der hat, nicht Kundenbewertung, der hat, ja
der kommt fast gleich heraus. Okay, das ist Turbo, Turbotakt. Dafür hat man dann noch
zwei Kerne mehr. Tja, muss mal gucken, was dann wichtig ist. Aber ich muss sagen, das
sieht mir doch hier relativ konkurrenzfähig aus. Wobei man halt sagen muss, 10 und 12
Kerne braucht man eigentlich nicht. Dann würde ich lieber einen 3700X nehmen oder irgendwie
so was. Für weniger als der, also auf dem Niveau. Also aktuell würde ich wahrscheinlich
den hier nehmen. An CPUs. So, und das entspricht dann ungefähr dem hier. 8 Kerne hat der hier
auch. Ja, dann würde ich den hier nehmen. Ah, guck mal, nur bei dem teureren kriegst
du hier den Multiplikator. Ich würde wahrscheinlich trotzdem den hier nehmen irgendwie, so bauchgefühlmäßig.
Jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer überlegen. Aber ich finde, das sieht relativ konkurrenzfähig
aus, was Intel jetzt hier gerade am Start hat. Glaubst du, Intels Grafikkarte werden alles
zerficken? Nö, warum sollten sie? Was hast du gegen LGA Sockel? Nix. Ich habe nur was
dagegen, das Intel alle furzlange neuen Sockel hat. AMD hat immer noch diese eklig schnell
kaputtbaren Dinge an ihren CPUs. Weiß ich nicht, was du meinst, keine Ahnung. Ich hatte
schon lange kein AMD-CPU mehr. Gut, mal gucken, ob ich irgendjemand hosten kann. Kann
wir irgendjemand hosten? Wen haben wir hier am Start? Irgendwie keiner da. Du folgst,
den folge ich denn. Keiner so wirklich am Start. Na gut Leute, bis denn, machts gut,
wir sehen uns, legt die Tage, CU!
Wir sehen uns, legt die Tage, CU!